Musik
Musik Ein bisschen viel Gain, oder? Gain, Gain.
Selbst in deinem Klatschenwagen, null Energie drin, null Anspannung, null Körperspannung, man sieht die Köpfe hängen, also der eine Kopf, den du hast, der hängt.
Also ich bin, ich weiß nicht, wie es dir gab, ich bin noch völlig fertig, ich bin noch völlig fertig, ich meine, wir sind ja auch frohe Leichnamfreaks.
Das ist eine Anmoderation, oh ne, ich weiß nicht. Ne, ne, nee. Veto, Veto, da leg ich direkt nur Veto ein. Das war ganz schön krass. Fron Leichnam war echt krass. Nee, nee, nee. Das ist keine vernünftige Anmoderation, das ist kein vernünftiger Gag, das ist ein geklauter Gag. Beginne niemals eine Show mit einem geklauten Gag. Von wann? Wir haben für uns selber geklaut. Wenn du schon direkt gebrochen hast. Ja, das ist das Schlimmste, was du machen kannst. Ich will einen guten Anfang. Ich will, dass die ersten zehn Minuten gut sind. Der Rest ist mir scheißegal, hauptsache die ersten zehn Minuten sind gut. Ich will, dass du alle Gags, die du hast in den ersten zehn Minuten rausballerst. Keine Gnade. Also wie immer, alle drei raushalten. Danach sind wir auf uns alleine gestellt. Und go. Okay, wir fangen an mit einem guten Lied. Es ist 1996, meine Freundin ist weg um neunzig in der Südsee. Ja, mein Budget war klein, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Kennt er, geiler Song, Kennt er. Herzlich willkommen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, zu Das Podcast-Ufo, Ihrer herzlich lauwarm aus letzter Woche nochmal aufgewärmten Showunterhaltung. Wir schimpfen uns das Podcast-UFO. Keep it, das Podcast-UFO ist unser Claim. Und wen Sie da gerade gehört haben, Stefan Titzel. Auch ich bin wieder da. Herzlich willkommen zum Podcast-UFO, zu der Aufzeichnung der 22. Folge. Und ich muss sagen, irgendwas ist noch im Moment los. Wir sind nicht ganz regelmäßig im Moment. Liegt aber an den Feiertagen. Liegt an frohen Leichenhaben. Liegt auch an den Feiertagen, ja, es liegt aber auch daran, dass du jetzt professionellen Sprechunterricht nimmst. In der Tat, in der Tat. Ich möchte ganz ehrlich mal sagen, man merkt das schon, es kommt schon durch. Der Stefan ist ja ein fleissiger Student und in der Universität lernt er nicht nur Lesen und Schreiben, sondern auch Sprechen. Ja, will ich sprechen, aber das ist wirklich was anderes, als ob man jetzt, wenn man was vorliest oder was vorträgt, wo man den Text schon kennt, ist das was ganz anderes. Da wurde mir gesagt, das kann ich, aber wenn ich jetzt so das Gefühl habe, wenn ich frei reden kann, wenn ich nicht genau weiß, wo das Ende des Satzes hinführt noch, wo dieser Satz hinführt, wie ich vor zehn Minuten angefangen habe, dann weiß ich nicht genau, ob das immer so gut ist. Aber dafür sind wir ja alle hier und das ist ja alles nur. Das Podcast-Uvo ist ja so riesen, so ein Practice-Raum, so ein angstfreier Raum. Absolut, wir sind hier, um zu lernen. Also die Zuschauer sollen auch die Zuhörer lernen und mal so ein bisschen Gags eingehen und auch mal schlechte Gags durchwinken. Also das sind verschiedene Skills, die bei unseren Zuhörern gesteigert werden. Und bei uns natürlich zu sprechen. Was habt ihr eigentlich Fronleichnam gemacht? Nein, nein, nein. Was habt ihr doch, das will ich gerne mal wissen. Schreibt das mal in die Kommentare unter dieses Video.
Fronleichnam war in Berlin überhaupt kein Feiertag.
Da war aber kein Feiertag. Ich war einkaufen. Ich war einen ganz normalen
Tag verlebt. Ich war in einem Kaufhaus
und habe Gewürze getestet.
Ich habe ganz viele Gewürze getestet.
In Berlin im Kaufhof, da gibt es unten so eine grosse Gourmetabteilung
und da gibt es verschiedene Gewürze, so grosse
Kästen, wo man Gewürze sich abfüllen kann
und die kann man auch alle riechen. So irgendwie
hundert Stück oder was auch immer. Gewürze aus aller Welt und Gewürzmischungen und für Brathandel und für Frühstücksquark und für jedes Gericht der Welt gibt es eine eigene Gewürzmischung und die habe ich alle gerochen und am Ende war mir so schlecht, ich hätte mich fast übergeben. Da waren teilweise echt Gewürzmischungen dabei. Wow! Gewürzmischungen riechen immer gleich. Also wenn man viele, wenn man in Gewürzläden geht, ich weiß nicht, ob es sowas gibt, aber wenn man in Läden geht, wo es sehr viele Gewürze gibt, Gewürzerien, ja, Gewürzerien, dann ist es immer so, dass man wirklich den gleichen Geruch in der Nase hat, weil alle Gewürze auf einmal ergeben halt diesen gleichen Geruch. Das ist eine gute Frage, das denke ich mir auch immer in Fußgängerzonen, wenn sich ganz viele Parfümungs- und Körpergerüche und Körperflüssigkeiten aufeinandertreffen, ab einer gewissen Anzahl von Gerüchen ist es einfach immer derselbe Geruch, genau wie bei Farbe.
Farbe, Farbe, Farbe, wenn du alle Farben zusammenpansch, dann ist es irgendwann eine sehr Farbe. Ich nenne es ja das Douglas-Phänomen. Also Douglas, alle Douglas-Läden riechen gleich.
Und zwar weil die halt alle auch ganz viele Parfums haben, die irgendwann einfach den Douglas-Parfum-Geruch herausspucken. Weil das ist ja so, alle Läden riechen gleich. Es gibt auch dieses klassische Oma-Parfum, ne? Parfum? Parfum, das jede Oma trägt. Und ich frage mich immer, wenn man in so einer Parfümerie hingeht und fragt, ich hätte gerne dieses klassische Oma-Parfum, wissen die, was gemeint ist? 47, 11, ja in Köln. Also in Köln ist es relativ, doch, da haben es wirklich sehr viele Frauen, haben das. Und es war ja auch so... Ich habe das gar nicht in der Nase gerade, ich kann das gerade gar nicht zuordnen, was das ist. Wir sind schon bei unserem Thema. Versuch mal den Geruch zu beschreiben, versuch jetzt mal den Geruch zu beschreiben, so dass er sich der Zuhörer sich vorstellen kann. Also ich sage ja immer, das Riechen ist ja sehr nah auch am Schmecken. Und deswegen würde ich es am ehesten wahrscheinlich mit so, also würde ich sagen, es riecht süsslich, etwas kann süsslich riechen, etwas kann bitter riechen, etwas kann feurig riechen, etwas kann spannend schwarz riechen, etwas kann leicht, kann hart riechen, etwas kann weich riechen, das sind immer so die klassischen Attribute. Reich riechen. Reich, du riechst arm, Fluatine riecht nach fritten Fett, kann man sagen. Genau. Das sind so diese Dinge, mit denen man... Nach Eis. Wie riecht Eis? Es gibt ja diese Eisbonbons, wo auch kein Mensch weiß, was das für eine Geschmacksrichtung sein soll, weil wonach schmeckt denn Eis eigentlich? Ich glaube, das sind einfach gefrorene Bonbons. Gefrorene Bonbons. Genau, wenn man später einen Bonbon haben möchte, aber nicht so viel Zeit hat, deswegen gefrorenes nimmt. Bonbon. Bonbon. Wir sind tatsächlich wieder bei der ersten Folge. Ich glaube, es war die allererste Folge, wo wir Bonbon festgelegt haben. Wir haben es zweiundzwanzig Folgen, haben wir es geschafft und jetzt sind wir wieder da, wo wir angefangen haben. Das war tatsächlich damals die einzige Notiz, mit der ich in den Podcast gegangen habe. Ich habe ihm gesagt, hey, Stefan Titzel, dieser Typ,
mit dem ich beim Comedypreis wirklich eine richtig
gute Show aufs Parkett gelegt habe.
Das war groß. Ja, es wurde auf dem roten Teppich mehr
gelacht als auf der Bühne.
Nur wegen Stefan Titzel tatsächlich. Und deswegen
dachte ich mir, mit dem muss ich mal einen Podcast machen.
Habe mich in der Tonkabine mit ihm gequetscht und hatte
eine einzige Aufzeichnung auf meinem Textdokument
und das war Bonbon
Aussprache, Fragezeichen. Weil das ist auch einer dieser Worte, die man nicht wirklich gut aussprechen kann, wo man immer drüber stolpert, genauso wie Parfum. Oder Croissant, Croissant. Croissant oder, na gut, es gibt, ja, oder Cappuccino, Trottoir, Trottoir, Macchiato. Ne, das ist sehr einfach, aber das ist ja geil. Ich habe ja zwei Beispiele, die überhaupt nicht das beschreiben wollen. Kurz mal so eine Podcast-Ufo-History-Runde eingelegt. Das waren die Anfänge. Das war der Rückblick. So hat es angefangen. Und jetzt sind wir schon hier, sind gealtert, sind ein halbes Jahr älter, sind in der 22. Folge mittlerweile angekommen, haben fast jede Woche eine Folge rausgehauen. Es ist aber nicht mehr anstrengend, manchmal macht es Spaß, manchmal sehr hart, weil wir uns halt eine Stunde lang reden. Aber es ist tatsächlich, ich habe mir auch die erste Folge letztes Mal wieder angehört, auf dem Weg zum Bahnhof mitten in der Nacht, und das war schon ganz okay. Also es ist eigentlich immer blöd, wenn man die erste Folge hört und denkt, ey, das ist gar nicht so schlecht eigentlich, weil wir hören am besten jetzt auf, besser wird es nicht. Ja, auf der anderen Seite, mir ist aufgefallen, in der ersten Folge rede ich wahnsinnig schnell, und dann rede ich jede Folge kontinuierlich ein bisschen langsamer. Also ich glaube, in Folge 100 müsst ihr mich auf doppelte Geschwindigkeit oder so stellen, weil da bin ich spätestens so langsam geworden, dass man mir nicht mehr ganz folgen kann. Das ist schon interessant, dass man auch so eine Entwicklung sich selbst verfolgt hat. Also ich hätte das noch nie, dass ich wirklich so eine Entwicklung, das ist ja genau wie, wenn man jeden Tag ein Bild von sich macht, dann hast du auch irgendwie gefühlt, so eine Entwicklung siehst du, aber wenn du jede Woche einen Podcast aufnimmst, hast du das auch, das ist wie so ein Tagebuch, was wir halt machen, nur wöchentlich.
Ja, das stimmt. Also wenn man lange Leute nicht sieht, dann kann man oft grosse Veränderungen an die feststellen.
Das ist tatsächlich so. Und ich habe mich tatsächlich wieder an zurückerinnert.
Ich hatte ja lange Gitarrenunterricht, und zwar mit zwei anderen Mädchen in der Dreiergruppe.
Und eines dieser Mädchen habe ich dann tatsächlich, glaube ich, so drei Jahre, nachdem ich mit Gitarrenunterricht aufgehört habe, mal wieder in der U-Bahn gesehen. In der klassischen Situation, man sitzt in der U-Bahn und direkt geht. Mit dem Hütchen vor sich, sie hat so einen kleinen Hut vor sich gehabt und mit der Gitarre. Und sie wurde wahnsinnig gut, die kann mittlerweile wahnsinnig gut spielen. Das stimmt, genau. Und ich habe Zeitungen verkauft und man trifft sich, man winkt sich kurz zu. Und es gibt ja diese tolle Situation, dass sich jemand, den man kennt, direkt in der U-Bahn sich einem gegenüber setzt und dann ist immer so ein bisschen dieses soziale Schach anfängt zu spielen, so macht man Augenkontakt, wie lange wartet man, bevor man es komplett aufgibt, soll man was machen? Und das Problem war, dass sie in den drei Jahren, in denen ich sie nicht gesehen habe, bestimmt 30 oder 40 Kilo zugenommen hat. Also sie sah wirklich aus wie ein anderer Mensch und sie sah genauso aus wie ihre Mutter,
wo immer ihre Mutter sie zum Gitarrenverricht gebracht hat.
Ich dachte mir immer, mein Gott, ist das eine grosse Mutter, da ist ganz schön viel Mutter da an diesem Mensch.
Und sie sah so aus, als hätte sie in der Zeit ihre Mutter aufgegessen. Also die drei Jahre lang hat sie gebraucht, um Stück für Stück ihre Mutter aufzuessen.
Und jetzt stand sie eben davor, als Tochter Mutter kommt und man hat. Das habe ich schon oft gehört, dass wenn man aufhört, Gitarre zu spielen, dass man wahnsinnig doll zunehmen. Das habe ich schon ernst oft gehört. Genau, deswegen spielen auch Leute einfach Gitarre, um einfach nur ein bisschen abzunehmen. Ja genau, das habe ich schon auch gehört. Man kann süchtig werden tatsächlich vom Gitarre spielen. Ja, ich weiß. Das kann passieren. Deswegen steht auch auf allen Gitarren immer drauf, Gitarre spielen kann tödlich sein oder so. Genau, deswegen muss man bei vielen Lokalen auch nach draußen gehen, um Gitarre zu spielen. Ja, Passiv-Gitarre spielen ist das Allerschönste. Exterte Gitarrenbereiche. An Flughäfen, genau, an Bahnsteigen. Ich habe noch nie einen Akkord ausprobiert. Gitarre habe ich schon mal, aber Akkord habe ich, weiss nicht, eh mehr zu gefährlich. Auf jeden Fall saßen wir dann uns gegenüber die ganze Fahrt und ich habe tatsächlich erst nach zehn Minuten gemerkt, wer mir da eigentlich gegenüber gesetzt hat, wer da zwischen den Fettfalten eigentlich verborgen liegt. Meine gute alte Bekannte, naja, also, aber da muss ich ganz kurz um kurz zum Fazit. Oh, Florian, die macht Dickenwitze. Hey, mal kurz alle kurz. Ja, naja gut, wenn einer, ne, also das ist ja genauso. Man muss sagen, Florentin hat wahnsinnig abgenommen. Das ist ja dieses schwarzen Argument, dass nur Schwarze über schwarze Witze machen dürfen. Dürfen machen. Und um ganz kurz zum Fazit zu kommen. Wenn man jemandem gegenüber sitzt in der U-Bahn, den man seit drei Jahren nicht gesehen hat und in der Zeit ein für ein Landlebewesen unnormales Gewicht angelegt hat, dann ist es in der Verantwortung des dicken Menschen, den anderen darauf aufmerksam zu machen, du erkennst mich jetzt nicht sofort, aber wir kannten uns mal. Und es wird wahrscheinlich, wenn wir das nicht gleich aufklären, eine fucking unangenehme, eineinhalbstündige Fahrt, es war S-Bahn, nicht U-Bahn, und ich habe mich in meinem Buch verkrochen. Also es war sehr unangenehm, es war tatsächlich sehr unangenehm. Irgendwann kann man ja auch nicht mehr ansprechen, ne? Ne, genau nicht nach zehn Minuten, nachdem man sich hingesetzt hat, kann man nicht einfach sagen, so aus dem Nichts heraus so, na Nina, hey, wie geht's dir? Ich hab das gar nicht erkannt, weil du mittlerweile zwei Menschen groß bist. Weil du so andere Frisur hast, so ein bisschen, ja. Das hab ich aber, das hat man ja auch gehabt, also da war ich in der U-Bahn und dann hab ich, ich hab ja irgendwie vor drei Jahren Abi gemacht und dann hab ich mit einem Mädchen Sport gehabt und das ist halt so eine Bekannte, aber ich kannte sie jetzt nicht so, dass ich sagen würde, ich würde sie auf einer Straße irgendwie groß begrüßen. Und dann habe ich sie halt hier in Köln wieder getroffen, dann war sie in der U-Bahn, saß direkt vor mir und dann, wie du gesagt hast, irgendwann so nach zehn Minuten ist die Chance einfach vorbei, Hallo zu sagen. Ist einfach weg. Und dann guckt man sich so an und dann haben sie, irgendwie haben unsere Blicke sich getroffen. Und dann gucken wir uns so an und gucken uns weiter an. Und ich sehe so in ihren Augen, ja okay, wir einigen uns beide drauf, wir gucken jetzt einfach wieder weg. Und wir kennen uns einfach nicht und nichts ist okay und ich schau aus. Und es war genau so und das war sehr gut. Man kann sich mit Blicken echt auf einigen. Es hat sehr gut funktioniert, Das ist so Social Awkwardness im Keim ersticken. Man muss es erkennen und im Keim ersticken. Das ist der Plan. Ja, das ist gut. Das ist wirklich gut. Aber zurück zum Thema. Wir haben aber riechen. Genau, ich wurde von einem Fuchs angegriffen letzte Woche. Ich war im Park unterwegs und da sind immer Füchse unterwegs. Das sind nachtaktive Fucking-Biester. Und da gibt es einige Füchse, die jetzt gerade Kinder bekommen haben und da laufen ganz viele kleine Füchse durch die Gegend und auch grosse Füchse. Und was machen Füchse für ein Geräusch? Oder Smisma, je nachdem. Also Weibchen machen Smisma, glaube ich. Smisma. Ich glaube, sie sind gar nicht so weit weg von dem Wal auch eigentlich. Ja, das stimmt. Vor allem, weißt du, was ich mir mal frage, also wir sind ja auch, weil das im Sinne beim Riechen, also Hören auch und bei Sinneswahrnehmungen. Und Hunde hören ja zum Beispiel Töne, die wir gar nicht hören. Also die hören sehr hohe Töne, deswegen gibt es ja immer diese lustige Situation, wenn Leute in diese Pfeife blasen und Hunde rasten für euch aus und man denkt, ja, Idiot, ich höre nichts. Und das ist ja auch so, ich frage mich angenommen, wir würden irgendwie mehr wahrnehmen können, also wir hätten auch diese Frequenzen, würden wir dann irgendwie Füchse reden hören oder so? Oder vielleicht reden die auf Frequenzen, die wir nicht wahrnehmen, aber wir verstehen es einfach nur nicht. Oder ist der Mensch schon so weit, dass er weiss, dass Tiere nicht so kommunizieren? Ich glaube, man ist mittlerweile so weit auf Frequenzen. Man findet ja auch Federmäuse, kommunizieren auch über Ultraschall, das haben wir ja auch rausgefunden mittlerweile. Ja, es gibt ja auch dieses Gerücht, dass Enten kein Echo erzeugen, dass Entenquaken kein Echo erzeugt. Echt? Aus irgendeinem abgefahrenen Grund. Jedes Geräusch der Welt erzeugt ein Echo, außer Entenquaken. Das ist ein Ding. Das habe ich mal bei Mythbusters gesehen. Ich kann mich aber nicht erinnern, ob der Myth gebastelt wurde oder nicht. Meistens kommt dann Werbung, man schaltet um. Ja, genau. Bei Mythbusters nur durch komische Seppen landet immer. Ich habe mal eine andere Funny-Tier-Story. Ich habe gehört, dass Hummeln gar nicht fliegen dürften, weil die so groß sind und so kleinen Flügel haben. Aber genug aus dem Tierreich. Das hat doch irgend so ein Siebtklässler ausgerechnet, oder so. Nach meiner Rechnung könnten, also rechnet Dinge aus, die einfach so nicht sind. Der Mond ist grösser als die Sonne. Nee. Bei mir kommt wieder eine Formel raus, Hummeln dürften gar nicht existieren. Genau, bei mir kommt raus Moritz, zu umständlich, deutsch, LK, dachte ich jetzt wegen Moritz. Ja, ja. Naja, ist ja auch nicht so wichtig. Bleibtreu, glaube ich, meinst du? Meinte ich ja tatsächlich, von Die Räuber, da spielt ja Moritz Bleibtreu mit.
Im Buch spielt er mit.
Ja genau, war das früher eigentlich, als es noch keine Filme gab, hat man sich dann drum gestritten, wer in einem Buch vorkommt.
Also gab es dann auch so eine Art Schauspieler, aber die halt so Buchfiguren waren. Es gab Namen, es gab den ersten Stefan, es gab den ersten Valentin, den ersten Florian, den ersten Fabian.
Die jemals in einem Buch aufgetaucht sind.
Und dann wollten die immer, dass ihr Name in dem Buch vorkommt, um sich selber so ein bisschen, das war wie Schauspieler, damals Namen. Man ging mit Namen hausieren. Dann gab es Namenagenturen und so. Einen Namen haben, man sagt ja, der hat einen Namen. Genau. Ja, das kommt ja daher. Einen Namen haben. Genau, jemanden beim Namen rufen, ja, Rang und Namen. Genau, Ruhm und Namen. Genau, einmal zwei Namen zu mitnehmen, das kommt alles aus dieser Zeit. Und ich war tatsächlich in diesem Kaufhaus unterwegs und habe Gewürze getestet. Und ich habe mich gefragt, weil du ja auch schon angesprochen hast und eine sehr vernünftige Analyse dargeboten hast, dass Riechen ja sehr nah am Schmecken ist. Und ich dachte mir immer, warum reicht es nicht, Essen einfach zu riechen? Warum reicht es für den Genussfaktor nicht aus, dass man Dinge einfach nur riecht und nicht isst? Weil, und da hast du das Problem angesprochen, ein fundamentales Problem der Menschheit, ist ja nicht um den Genuss geht, sondern um Lebenserhaltung. Man muss ja essen. Ja, aber darüber sind wir ja lange drüber hinaus. Man isst ja heutzutage fast nur noch aus Genuss eigentlich. Ja, das stimmt. Aber dass du, wenn du irgendwie so einen schönen Schokoriegel hast, das ist dann reich daran zu riechen und du hast den Genuss erlebt, du weißt ja, wie es riecht, Genuss dann, aber du musst es trotzdem noch essen. Das ist schon komisch. Ich verstehe auch nicht, warum nicht jeder Mensch einfach so eine Infusion bei sich in der Küche hängen hat, wo er sich dann abends eine Stunde dranhängt und dann alles gegessen hat, was man braucht für den Tag oder für die Woche. warum nicht für die Woche, warum nicht fürs Jahr, warum soll denn der Geiz?
Weil Essen Spaß macht, du Pfeife.
Ja, aber das ist doch das Genuss, das kann man ja dann irgendwie so weit sein, dass man das mit Riechen aufnimmt, wie du schon sagst.
Ja, aber das reicht ja eben nicht.
Wenn man alles schon gegessen hat, vielleicht.
Die Tatsache, dass man viel essen muss, dass Dinge besser schmecken, wenn man viel isst, dass es nicht reicht, dass du einmal vom Snickers abbeisst und dann hast du das Erlebnis ja schon getan, sondern du musst das alles aufessen.
Ja, stimmt.
Das ist ein reich, dass du einmal vom Snickers abbeisst und dann hast du das Erlebnis ja schon getan, sondern du musst das alles aufessen. Ja, das stimmt. Das ist schon komisch. Oder wenn du M&Ms isst, dass man dann auch nicht nur ein M&M in den Mund tut, sondern alle gleichzeitig. Aber warum denn? Also schmeckt das dann besser oder ist das einfach so ein Gefühl, dass ich vernichte alles, so ein Machtgefühl, dass man viel einfach mehr hat.
So ein Nicht genug bekommen. Ich glaube, Menschen können oft nicht genug bekommen.
Und wenn die einmal was positiven ist.
Ich glaube, Menschen können oft den Zug nicht bekommen.
Und wenn sie was Positives, ich ignoriere das mal, und wenn die was Positives erleben, dann wollen sie es wieder erleben.
Und wieder erleben.
Die können einfach nicht genug bekommen von positiven Erlebnissen.
Um den Zug zu bekommen, musst du denken wie der Zug.
Das habe ich diese Woche gelernt.
Und wie denkt ein Zug so? Was denkt ein Zug? Und wenn du genau so am Bahnsteig stehst, bekommst du jeden Zug. Ist das die für den Bill-Garantien? Aber das ist ja abgefahren. Es gibt ja so Elektro-Lokomotiven und bei einem Elektromotor hast du ja keine Gangschaltung per se. Aber trotzdem, wenn du ein sehr massiges Objekt, wie zum Beispiel eine Lokomotive, anfahren lassen willst, kannst du nicht einfach mit dem höchsten Gang, sozusagen mit der höchsten Leistung anfangen, sonst bricht die Achse durch oder die Zuschauer sterben oder was auch immer. Deswegen brauchst du schon so eine Art Gangschaltung, dass sich das so langsam hochsteigert, aber du hast ja keine mechanische Limitation, du kannst das ja einfach willkürlich festsetzen, dass es meinetwegen halt ein Watt, dann acht, dann sechzehn, dann whatever. Das ist ja sicher, dass mit Watt Züge funktionieren, Elektronzüge. Mit Watte hauptsächlich, ja. Und deswegen hat man sich dafür entschieden, einfach die Tonleiter zu nehmen, dass man einfach die Züge anfahren lässt in den Frequenzen oder in den Watt oder Energiezahlen in G-Dur, die die Tonleiter erzeugen. Achte da mal drauf, wenn da so eine Elektro-Lok anfängt und du denkst, was, das ist ein Tonleiter. Das ist das Geräusch, bevor eine Ansage kommt beim Bahnsteig. Das hast du gerade verwechselt. Ach Mann, auch beim Spurentin. Du bist so oft am Bahnsteig, da muss man doch mal erwarten, dass du das auseinanderhalten kannst. Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht. Wieder einmal kommst du nicht durchs Leben, ohne zu scheitern. Ja, aber kurz bevor mir der Geldbeutel geklaut wird von Taschendieben, höre ich das auch mal. Das ist auch komisch. Wo ich mir denke, ist es so ein, fühlen sich Taschendiebe
dann gut, wenn diese Durchsage kommt,
Achtung, ist denn Taschendiebe auf dem Bahnhof?
Denken die sich so, yeah, motherfucker.
Das ist wie so ein Game Over.
Der Place ist gerade für uns
gestorben. Ja, oder es wird einfach
nur, es ist Level Up. Es wird einfach
nochmal schwieriger. Ab jetzt kommt der Endgegner.
Ja, ich glaube nicht, ich glaube, das ist schon
so ein, ist ja, ich glaube, es sind ja wie Ninjas, die wollen einfach nicht entdeckt werden. Und sobald sie entdeckt werden, sind es einfach die schlechtesten. Genau, wie ich mal gehört habe, das sind die japanischen Ninjas vielleicht einfach nur die schlechtesten Ninjas, weil sie ja mittlerweile erkannt wurden. Wenn man ja weiss, dass es hier gibt, dann darf man drüber nach. Ja, oder geh auf neingag.com, kann man auch machen. Ich weiß nicht, wer im Glashaus sitzt, sollte vielleicht nicht mit Steinen werfen. Kannst du mir nichts nachweisen. Wenn du es mir nicht nachweisen kannst, ist nichts passiert. Ich war letztens, ich habe, apropos Ninja, ist ja auch eine gute Übertragung, der Digital Ninja ist ja so der Pop-Up-Blocker. Ich habe ja ein Fucking Virus und das Problem ist, dass immer zwei Tabs erscheinen und ich weiß nicht, wie ich dem herwerden kann. Deswegen dachte ich, hol mir einfach so einen Ad-er, dass Pop-ups einfach generell nicht mehr funktionieren. Ja, aber Moment, also du hast den Status ja schon erreicht, dass du Seiten bekommst, die du schon kennst. Du kennst mittlerweile alles, was auf dessen Seiten ist. Ich bin ja immer normalerweise froh, wenn Seiten auftauchen. Freue ich mich immer darüber, neue Sachen, die man entdecken kann. Das ist wie ein Gast, ja, wie jemand, der anklopft. Noch eine neue Nachbarin, die kann mich noch nicht, oh, die kann dich noch nicht, muss ich, bleiben Sie doch, Kuchen backen und für die neue Nachbarin noch was.
Und das ist halt so, man entdeckt immer neue Dinge, aber du bist ja bei einem so einem Status, du hast die Seiten, die du irgendwie dein Virus aufruft, die kennst ja schon irgendwie auswendig und du hast dich schon dafür entschieden, die nicht mehr haben zu wollen.
Ja, naja, es ist ein Virus, der dafür sorgt, dass in alle 20 Minuten zwei Tabs aufgehen mit irgendwelcher fucking Spam-Werbung und dann auch so, sie werden irgendwieich innerhalb von zwei Wochen. Und dann ist so eine Art Blog-Eintrag von irgendwie Markus, der schreibt, ich habe das gemacht und bei mir jetzt funktioniert. Und diese fucking Markus-Fresse, wenn ich den nochmal sehe, da werde ich wirklich aggressiv, weil ich diesen Penner immer sehe. Und es ist einer dieser Tabs, die man nicht einfach schliessen kann, sondern dass da nochmal so eine Maske kommt, wollen sie wirklich die Seite verlassen, ja oder nein. Das wäre doch ein super Film, wenn plötzlich, also so ein Ende für einen Film, wenn du plötzlich irgendwie stirbst und die letzten Momente, die du siehst, sind so ein, wie Markus plötzlich zu dir hingeht und irgendwie deine Seele nimmt oder geht. Das wäre gut, das finde ich gut. Und jetzt habe ich mir einen Pop-Up-Blocker installiert und der zeigt dir immer an, wenn er Pop-Ups blockiert hat. Das heißt, er zeigt dir an, wie viele Pop-Ups nicht angezeigt wurden. Durch Pop-Ups. Er zeigt durch Pop-Ups an, dass er gerade ein Pop-Up blunt geht hat. Wie gut war das denn?
Okay, das ist meine neue Style-Up-Idee. Ein Pop-Up-Blocker, bei dem ein Pop-Up kommt, sobald ein Pop-Up geblockt wurde.
Genau, wenn du ein Pop-Up zumachst, kommen zwei neue.
Aber immer mit einem schönen neuen Bildchen, irgendwie so ein animiertes GIF, würde ich dazukommen.
Genau, und da dachte ich mir aber auch, der Typ kann mir ja erzählen, was er will, oder?
Also der kann ja da hinschreiben, was er will, einfach. Ich habe heute drei Pop-Ups geblockt, die hast du ja nicht gesehen. Das kann ich ja nicht nachprüfen, weil ich sie nicht gesehen habe. Das ist so ein bisschen die letzte Reihe Version von diesen Apps in dem Browser, die einfach sagen, na ja, ich habe heute 18 Sachen gemacht. Pop-Ups oder wie die heißen. Pop-Up, habe Pop-Up weggepoppt und ja, das lief ganz gut. Kann man nicht sehen. Aber nochmal zu deinem Virus. Ist es nicht, wenn man ein Virus programmieren kann, relativ blöd, nur zwei Seiten immer aufrufen zu lassen, die irgendwann einfach als Spam irgendwie erkannt wurden? Ich meine, ich klicke ja auch nicht irgendwann mal, nur weil die Viagra-Mail zum hundertsten Mal kommen, klicke ich ja auch nicht drauf, sondern ich werde sie wieder wegnehmen, weil ich schon auch ein zweites Mal verstanden habe, dass es vielleicht eine Viagra-Mail sein kann. Ja, ja, wer tut erst mal so alt wie ich, dann reden wir weiter. Aber wenn man ein Virus programmieren kann, warum macht man dann sowas und nicht irgendwie was Cooles, dass du plötzlich was kaufen musst oder so, oder die hecken dich in deine Paypal-Daten rein? Naja, es wurden ja nicht alle Viren programmiert, es gibt ja auch natürliche Viren, die einfach entstehen im digitalen Cyberspace, die einfach durch Mutationen und Selektionen einfach entstehen. Ebola. Das ist ja nicht alles von Mensch gemacht, es gibt ja auch digitales Ebola. Ja, habe ich auch gehört. Also so ist es ja nicht. Naja, es geht heute um Gerüche, was ist denn dein Lieblingsgeruch? Da habe ich auch drüber nachgedacht. Und ich muss sagen, ich bin ja jemand, oft sagen Leute, das gefällt mir nicht, das rieche ich nicht gern. Aber ich rieche eigentlich die meisten gerne. Auch Chlor zum Beispiel liebe ich. Ich liebe den Geruch von Chlor und ich liebe den Geruch von Tiefgaragen, also Benzingeruch. Finde ich total geil. Ja, Benzin, auch sowas wie Nagellacke oder so Nagellack entfernen. Ja, intensive, ganz beissende Lachen. Klebstoff, Edding, finde ich super. Ich finde, ich stehe gerne an Tankstellen und rieche den Geruch. Man soll das halt nicht machen, aber ich mache es halt, da bin ich badass, da bin ich einfach ein Riskaker. Aber hast du schon mal dieses am Kleber schnüffeln, high werden riechen? Habe ich nicht verstanden. Das habe ich auch nicht verstanden. Das habe ich nie gemacht und ich weiß auch nicht, ob das einfach nur eine Urban Legend ist, dass das funktioniert. Doch, ich habe es mal gemacht, ich habe es mal gemacht, seitdem bin ich so, wie ich bin, aber ich habe nicht genau verstanden, was es mit mir macht. Du kannst dich an keinen Tag davor mehr erinnern. Ja, nee. Aber du weißt nicht, ob es funktioniert. Nee, ich weiß nicht mehr, ich glaube schon. Boah, ich wäre auch geil ein Superheld, ein Superheld, der irgendwie, wenn er so viel Klebe geschnüffelt hat, Mr. Glue oder so. Glumander. Glumander, der dann immer sich von Haus zu Haus mit Klebstofffäden schwingen kann zum Beispiel. Ja, und da wo immer irgendwelche Zettel an ihm kleben. So Pin-Up-Man. Mr. Pop-Up. Pop-Up, ja, Mr. Pop-Up. Pop-Up. Pop-Up ist eigentlich ein gutes Wort, der Pop-Up. Da wird unser Pop-Schutz jetzt auch auf die Probe gestellt. Man hat ja immer vor ein Mikrofon, so ein kleines Felding, damit man nicht die Atemgeräusche hört. Das ist die grosse Pop-Up-Challenge. Und wer von uns hat den besseren Pop-Schutz? Pop-Up. Man nennt die Pop-Schutz, weil beim Wort Pop ganz viel Luft entweicht, Nebentönen aus dem Mund. Und wenn man hören würde, das heißt, wir können jetzt endlich mal unter Beweis stellen, dass wir gute Popp-Pos haben. Und man denkt sich immer, wenn man so ein Ding kauft, naja, Pop werde ich jetzt nicht so oft sagen, aber wir haben gerade gemerkt, hey, das ist unser Wort, hey, das ist genau das Wort, was ich am liebsten ausspreche. Aber man muss auch sagen, ich habe nämlich, ich habe ja wie gesagt dieses Sprechtraining, da muss ich was aufnehmen für, und da meinte meine Sprechtrainerin, dass ich, obwohl ich Pop-Up-Popschutz habe, dass es trotzdem nicht gut klingt, also dass mein P trotzdem nicht gut klingt und es würde an mir liegen, ich würde das P zu doll aussprechen, man kann es ja auch in sich rein nuscheln so, also man kann das P auch wesentlich entspannter sagen, man kann es auch weglassen und ich hau dann immer so, ich bin so ein nach vorne Mensch, ich hau das immer so raus, auch wie, duura-Fieber. Aber man kann es doch alles in sich reinlabern. Ja. Pop-Schutz, Pop-Schutz. Geht schon auch. Geht auch. Pop, pop and lock. Wollen wir nochmal singen zwischendurch? Ja, es kam gut an. Somebody, somebody, es kam gut an in der Marktforschung, glaube ich, dass wir singen. Wahnsinnig gut, ja. Letztens habe ich mit einer Zufallin gesprochen, die meinte, ja, sie schaltet immer weg, wenn wir am Anfang singen. Deswegen dachte ich, singen wir doch einfach nochmal in der Mitte, einfach um zu sehen, ob sie es ernst meint. Sie schaltet weg, wenn wir am Anfang singen und hört dann nicht mehr in die Folge rein? Das weiß ich nicht, das habe ich nicht nachgefragt. Wie kann man denn am Anfang wegschalten? Da muss ich dann weiter Zeitung verkaufen. Du musstest dich danach weiter prostituieren. Ja, geht leider nicht anders. Ja, ich weiß es nicht. Ich glaube, das ist so eine Art Protestaktion, die nicht so gut funktioniert. Kann man nicht eigentlich sagen, so Ikea ist es nicht auch nur ein Strassenstrich für objektophile Menschen? Ich habe hier nämlich immer auf meiner Notiz, da wo meine Podcastnotizen sind, ist auch das gleiche Textdokument, wo meine Tweetideen stehen. Weil, wie viele nicht wissen, man kann beim Mac nur ein Textdokument machen, also jemals. Man kann nur ein Textdokument machen, da muss man ganz viele Sachen einreiben.
Und da steht das gesamte menschliche Wissen des Macs.
Ja, man kommt noch ein bisschen durcheinander immer, aber das muss man halt so machen. Man kann nicht zwei machen, das ist nicht möglich. Ich finde auch, alle Ikea riechen gleich, wo du gerade bei Ikea warst. Ich finde, alle Revis riechen gleich. Und da habe ich damals mal irgendwie für so ein Schulklassenfach mussten wir irgendwie für ein Schulfach Schulfach. Ja, mussten wir irgendwie in so einen Laden gehen und interviewen. Und dann haben wir sehr komisch und immer sehr penetrant nachgefragt. Penetrant, penetrant. Und dann kam irgendwann raus, dass es einen Rewe-Duft gibt. Also es gibt einen Duft, den man … Gibt es Rewe eigentlich in München oder Berlin und so? Ja Ja, ja. Und da gibt es so einen kleinen Duft, den die oben versprühen immer, damit man sich gleich irgendwie zuhause fühlt in Berlin-Rewe. Ach was. Ja, jede Filiale hat den Duft, bekommt den immer und versprüht den. Das hast du rausgefunden? Ja. Kann man den auch kaufen? Ja, haben wir auch gefragt, so als Deo oder so. Und dann fühlen sich alle direkt, wollen irgendwie Sachen von die kaufen, weil sie sich daran erinnert fühlen, an diesen Impuls. Weiß ich nicht, kann man glaube ich nicht kaufen. Das ist ja schon eine gute Idee, ne? Man hat schon das Gefühl, dass alles riecht, außer alles, was mit einem selbst zu tun hat. Also auch so Wohnungen riechen und so, bei einem Freund zu Gast ist man riecht die Wohnung total intensiv, man riecht seine eigene Wohnung aber nicht so sehr, außer man ist mal irgendwie ein paar Monate weg und kommt dann wieder und denkt, das kann doch nicht wahr sein, so riecht meine
Wohnung, das ist ja grauenvoll. Man riecht ja auch seinen eigenen,
wenn man Mundgeruch hat, riecht man das ja auch selber nicht.
Da gibt es ja diesen Trick, dass man seine Hand
anleckt, zehn Sekunden
anleckt, also den Handrücken anleckt,
mit der Zunge, weil ja diese Mundgeruch
Partikel wohl auf der Zunge sind, zehn Minuten
wartet und dann riecht und dann
guckt, ob man halt Mundgeruch hat oder nicht.
Aber ich weiss nicht, ob das bringt, aber kurz ein bisschen wissen. Was ist denn dann riecht und dann guckt, ob man halt Mundgeruch hat oder nicht. Aber ich weiss nicht,
ob was das bringt. Aber kurz ein bisschen wissen.
Was ist denn eigentlich Riechen?
Pheromone?
Riechstoffe?
Botenstoffe? Botenstoffe.
Aber kann man Dinge denn aufriechen?
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage,
aber wir haben Stichwort Magnete wären. Sind Dinge irgendwann, sind Dinge, ist es, ich glaube, es ist keine Energie. Ich glaube, ich habe auch mal das Gefühl. Naja, es muss ja im weitesten Sinne Materie sein. Also irgendwas muss es ja schon sein, sonst wäre es ja nicht da. Man kann Dinge aufschnupfen. Ja, das ist schon klar. Aber kann man sie auch wegriechen? Oder hören Dinge irgendwann einfach auf zu riechen? Oder ist das, woraus sie bestehen, dasselbe, was riecht? Oder hat auch ein Brötchen Geruchsstoffe, die es aussondert, unabhängig davon, dass es Brötchen ist? Das sind es Arbeitsteilungen. Ich nehme da immer gern als Beispiel diese Diddle-Blöcke, die es damals gab, diese Geruchsblöcke. Habt ihr auch dieses was vergeben? Wir haben irgendwie gesammelt, so Blöcke gesammelt, die gerochen haben. Diddle war der Hypes, glaube ich, war der erste Hype, den ich nicht mitgemacht habe, war Diddle, wo ich mir dachte, ihr habt doch einen kompletten Schaden.
Da meine ich nicht mit. Das meine ich.
Und das war, also die haben auch immer aufgehört zu riechen und dann waren die uncool, dann konnte sie sich doch nicht mehr weiter verschenken.
Was ich aber hatte, war zum Beispiel so Simpsons Sticker, wo man so ein Sammelalbum hatte.
Da gab es dann manchmal auch so Geruchssticker, wo man dann irgendwie sowas wegrubbeln konnte und es hat dann einfach irgendwie immer nach Autoreifen gerochen oder so. Aber das hat mir auch so ein komischer Typ verkauft, ich weiß auch nicht genau, was das war. Aber das war komisch, vor allem es roch auch alles gleich. Da gab es dann einmal mal so einen Sticker von March, die irgendwie so einen Kuchen in der Hand hatte und dann war dieser Kuchen aus diesem Material und dann gab es irgendwie eine Situation, wo dieser dreiäugige Fisch irgendwie geangelt wurde und dann war dieser Fisch aus diesem Material und es roch exakt gleich. Also das war auch ganz, ganz seltsam. Entweder ist Marge eine sehr schlechte Köchin oder man kann einfach sagen, das ist Quatsch. Oder der Fisch hat irgendwie Erdbeerfüllung oder sowas. Also ich habe gehört, Menschen mit grossen Nasen können besser riechen, habe ich gehört. Menschen mit langen Beinen können besser laufen. Das habe ich mir auch gedacht. Ich habe mir gedacht, ich habe eine sehr grosse Nase und ich kann auch wirklich gut riechen. Ich rieche sehr gut. Also ich kann gut riechen. Also ich rieche Dinge gut. Im Deutschen ist es ein bisschen verworren. Und das heißt, also dass Leute, wie du sagst, mit langen Beinen schneller laufen können, dass Leute mit einem grossen Penis halt länger pinkeln müssen, das haben wir alle schon besprochen. Aber das heisst doch eigentlich, dass grosse Menschen eigentlich im Umkehrschluss die besseren Menschen sind, oder? Wieso, weil sie die meisten Dinger gross haben, oder wie? Ja, und weil es halt grössere Menschen sind. Größere Menschen, grössere Nasen sind besser, funktionsfähiger, also grosse Menschen sind auch funktionsfähiger. Ja, aber wenn du grösser bist, hast du ja auch automatisch eine grössere Nase. Dann ist ja alles grösser, das skaliert sich ja. Ist das so? Dann hast du ja auch grössere Augen. Ja, weil die Proportionen im Gesicht sind ja wahrscheinlich noch gleich, oder? Das weiss man nicht. Ich glaube schon. Also durchschnittlich gesehen. Ich glaube schon. Ich denke auch. Oder bist du einfach nur länger, dass du einfach nur grösser bist, aber nicht mehr Volumen hast.
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, es alles skaliert
sich hoch. Also bin ich der bessere Mensch.
Weiß ich nicht, ob sich das skaliert. Ja, guck das
mal nach, bitte. Okay.
Also in drei Folgen habe ich eine Antwort. Ich bereite
mal ein kleines Referat vor.
Mal, mal.
Ja, tolle, zählen wir doch
einfach mal nette Gerüche auf.
Machen wir doch mal so eine Wohlfühl-Oase. Einfach mal abschalten und jetzt macht mal alle die Augen einfach zu, adet mal tief ein und nimmt einfach mal Gerüche ganz bewusst wahr. Was ist da eigentlich in der Nähe? Und wie ist eure Wohnung? Was riecht hier eigentlich? Kann ich verschiedene Gerüche auseinanderhalten? Ist das da etwa die Blume? Ist das der Teppich? Die Katze, die Katze, da ist die Katze, das ist die Salami, das ist die Salami von drei Wochen, die du in der Ecke geziesst hast. Wo ist der Fisch, was ist es denn da links hinten, was rieche ich denn da, ist das Käsekuchen, eine Schraube, Rost, verschiedene Gerüche mischen sich zusammen und ergeben neue Gerüche. Rost plus Nutella ist Erdbeere. Handcreme plus Stecknadel ergibt Frippel. Wonach riecht Wind? Wonach riecht deine Wohnung? Wonach riecht Liebe? Wonach riecht deine Wohnung, das Florentin will? Das ist schwer zu sagen. Ich habe ja anfangs schon gesagt, dass man seine eigene Wohnung nicht riecht. Ja, aber was riecht du denn gerade? Wenn man sich konzentriert, wenn man sich konzentriert. Ich rieche gerade meine Socke, weil mein Popschutz ist eine Socke. Ich habe über mein Mikrofon einfach eine Socke gezogen und das ist mein Popschutz, aber natürlich eine gewaschene Socke, aber ich habe natürlich den Textilgeruch in der Nase. Eigentlich riecht man ja auch konstant seine eigene Nase, also ich glaube 95 Prozent der Gerüche sind ja die eigene Nase. Das heißt, eigentlich geht es gar nicht darum, hast du eine grosse oder eine kleine Nase, sondern hast du eine duftende Nase. Eigentlich. Ich habe mir deswegen so einen Wunderbaum in meine Nase gehangen. Ich rieche mal so einen, wie ist es, einen Wunderbaum von Autos? Ja, der dann auch nach neuem Auto riecht. Genau, ich habe mir so einen Neuwagengeruch in meine Nase gehangen. Aber das sind doch auch garantiert synthetische Geruchsstoffe, oder? Also das wird doch heutzutage genauso designt wie das Auto an sich, der Geruch, den der Kunde hat, wenn man ins Auto steigt. Das hat doch nichts mit dem Material zu tun. Das wird doch da reingesprüht oder hundertprozentig. Das ist das Erste, worüber Männer reden, wenn sie sich ein neues Auto kaufen. Das ist das Geruch des Neuwagens. Wenn man das nicht vermarkten würde, wenn man das dumm. Autohäuser ist mein absoluter Liebungsgeruch. Das möchte ich mal kurz sagen. In Autohäuser reinzugehen, diese Mischung aus Blech, Leder, Gummi und dann noch immer diese Glas und Geld.
Und Kreditkarten.
Das Geräusch, wenn eine Kreditkarte über so eine Theke
gekratzt wird.
Geräusch ist ja nochmal ein anderes Thema, da müssen wir jetzt höllisch
aufpassen, dass wir die nicht verbinden.
Gerüche ist ja was ganz Eigenes.
Aber ich mag zum Beispiel den Geruch von
Ich finde, Sinn ist auch eine gute
Sache. Wir können auch am weitesten Sinn über
Sinne sprechen. Wir können ja auch irgendwann nochmal eine Seefolge einschließen oder so. Aber was ist auch eine gute Sache. Wir können auch im weitesten Sinne über Sinne sprechen. Wir können auch irgendwann noch mal eine See-Folge
einschliessen oder so.
Aber was ist mit einem Top-Fünf
der Sinne machen vielleicht?
Also, dass wir einen Top-Five
aufstellen, der Top-Fünf, der
grossen fünf Sinne.
Wäre das was?
Ja, willst du das einfach spontan machen?
Schneidest du dann da oder was?
Ich will es spontan machen vielleicht einfach jetzt. Alles klar, okay. Okay, also bei mir auf Platz fünf ist Sehen. Das Unwichtigste bin ich nicht begeistert. Das meiste habe ich schon gesehen. Also jetzt mal im Ernst. Aber es muss trotzdem super wichtig für dich sein, sonst wäre es dann hier Platz fünf.
Ich meine, das ist ja ein guter Platz immer noch.
Ja, es ist natürlich schon relativ zentral, aber das meiste habe ich schon gesehen.
Also alles, was ich jetzt noch sehe, ist ja nur ein Konglomerat von Dingen, die ich schon mal gesehen habe.
Ich glaube, das Auge hört auch irgendwann auf zu arbeiten und sagt, da ist ein Hund, ich höre Hund,
ich rufe einfach ein Bild von einem Hund ab aus meinem Gehirn, scheisse auch drauf, wie der Hund wirklich aussieht. Ich glaube, die Augen machen letztlich gar nichts mehr. Ich glaube, so ab fünfzig machen die Augen nichts mehr. Da ist es nur noch Wind und Gehör, also das ist gar nichts mehr. Okay, bei mir ist auf Platz fünf fühlen. Ich finde es unwichtig, also das ist mit Absolut das Unwichtigste, finde ich. Fühlen. Ich habe mittlerweile auch alles gefühlt.
Ich kenne glatte Oberflächen, ich kenne weiche Oberflächen, ich kenne fällige Oberflächen und ich kenne deine Haare.
Aber du kannst einen anderen Menschen fühlen.
Ja, komm schon.
Okay, machen wir uns nichts vor.
Und dann Platz vier.
Okay, Platz vier ist der siebte Sinn bei mir. Der siebte Sinn? Ja. Magst du was dazu sagen? Ja? Warum? Warum was bewegt den siebten Sinn ein Florentil? Der siebte Sinn ist für mich einfach eigentlich ein Metasinn, der alle anderen Sinne in sich einschließt. Es ist eigentlich die Definition, die Weiterentwicklung von Sinn. Ja. Und das ist für mich auch der einzige Sinn, der wirklich Sinn macht. Okay.
Macht Sinn, ja.
Bei mir auf Platz vier ist Riechen.
Okay.
Ist für mich nicht wichtig unbedingt.
Also, sag mal einen schönen Geruch, sag mal was, was gut riecht.
Neuwagen.
Tann, Tannensapfen.
Ja, okay.
Tann, Baum. Bei mir auf Platz drei der sechste Sinn. Mit Bruce Willis, guter Film. Bei mir auf Platz drei ist Schmecken. Okay. Was sind denn so Geschmäcker, die du gerne hast? Was schmeckst du denn gerne so? Aber ist Schmecken wirklich noch mal ein eigener Sinn, neben Riechen? Ja, das habe ich mich gerade auch gefragt. Das ist ja wirklich fast dasselbe. Ja, vor allem wenn man nicht mehr riecht, kann man nicht mehr schmecken. Ich bin manchmal so krank, dass man eine Nase zusetzt,
dann kann ich nicht mehr schmecken. Ich schmecke dann nichts mehr einfach.
Aber es ist ja auch so, dass wenn du dir die Nase zuhältst, du nicht mehr
wirklich was schmeckst. Dass du dann nur noch
so diese Grundgeschmacksarten hast, nur noch so
bitter, sauer. Das heißt, wenn du was
essen musst, als Kind hat man das häufig gemacht, soweit ich weiss,
dass wenn man was essen muss, was man nicht mag,
in Blumenkohl oder so, dass man sich dann die Nase zuhält.
Und mein Biolehrer, mein Damaliger,
der hatte, der hat seine
Zunge irgendwie,
zumindest irgendwas
auf seiner Zunge verloren oder so,
ich weiß, ein Fahrradunfall
und hat irgendwie nicht seine Zunge verloren,
das muss ich nicht mehr sprechen, aber irgendwie
hat er irgendwas in seiner Nase
verloren, weshalb er nicht mehr
riechen konnte und er konnte auch nicht mehr schmecken. Und der hat jetzt alle, alles was er isst, schmeckt halt gleich. Aber er schmeckt halt, wenn zum Beispiel, er schmeckt halt Sachen, die unangenehm sind, die schmeckt man trotzdem noch durch. Also so ein Schnitzel für ihn schmeckt halt, wenn es nicht ganz frisch ist, so mega bitter, hat er immer gesagt. Also so ganz unangenehme Sachen, beissende Sachen, die schmeckt man noch durch. Aber die hat noch viel extremer, viel verstärkter. Das ist ganz schön scheiße, glaube ich. Trotzdem nur auf Platz vier bei mir, drei bei mir. Das ist spannend. Was ist bei dir?
Gut, bei mir ist auf Platz zwei schmecken. Tatsächlich sehr wichtig, es gibt vier Dinge, die schmecken gut. Brot zum Beispiel, Wasser schmeckt gut, Kartoffeln, M&Ms, Geleebananen, Booster, Tee, Kuchen, Torte, Schnitzel, Esspapier, Duplo, Apfel. Wir mussten die Folge an dieser Stelle unterbrechen, da Florentin das Ganze noch eine halbe Stunde weitergemacht hat. Um wertvolle Sendezeit nicht zu vergeuden, geht es jetzt gekürzt weiter. Eine Birne, ein Papierflieger mit Marmelade, also sowas geht auch. Okay. Was ist bei dir auf Platz zwei? Bei mir auf Platz zwei, da habe ich lange drüber nachgedacht, weil ich zwischen eines und zwei wirklich, also ich mache da wirklich ganz kleine Nuancen, sind nur unterschiedlich. Ich finde beides extrem wichtig. Bei mir auf Platz zwei ist Sehen. Sehen ist halt so mega wichtig, weil es ist halt, ich finde es gibt Sehen und auch, da muss ich jetzt Platz eins vorwegnehmen, Sehen und Hören sind halt die Dinge, mit denen man am ehesten so die Umwelt wahrnimmt und die wirklich mega entscheidend sind. Und wenn ein Tier, wenn ein Steinzeitmensch damals nicht sehen oder nicht hören konnte, war er einfach tot. Der wurde einfach getötet sofort. Das heißt, du würdest bei der klassischen Frage, würdest du lieber dein Augenlicht verlieren oder dein Gehör, würdest du tatsächlich sagen, du wärst lieber blind? Ja, lieber blind. Wirklich? Weil dir, also woran machst du das fest? Also wenn du blind bist, kannst du noch sprechen, du kannst halt noch mit Menschen wesentlich besser kommunizieren. Und wenn du hören kannst, kannst du auch, du kannst, also alles, was du siehst, hast du ja schon mal gesehen. Also wenn man irgendwann die Wahl hat, blind zu werden, ist das nicht so schlimm, weil du hast halt, du weißt ja mittlerweile, wie alle Dinge aussehen. Und deswegen kannst du, du kannst auch Fernsehfilme, kannst du noch gucken, Filme kannst du gucken, weil du halt die Dinge noch
wahrnimmst. Aber wenn du nicht mehr,
wenn du nicht mehr... Ja, aber du kannst, du siehst ja nichts.
Aber du hörst ja, du hörst ja, was passiert.
Ja, aber ich meine zum Beispiel, wenn du siehst,
könntest du ein Buch lesen. Dann schaust du dir
den Film nicht an oder liest du das Buch? Hörbücher.
Ja, aber Hörbücher, da hast du,
da ist dein ganzes Leben von Bjarne
Mädel bestimmt. Wer will das denn? Auch nicht mein Ding, unbedingt. Ist bei mir tatsächlich schon der Fall. Wäre bei dir tatsächlich Hören wichtiger? Es ist wirklich eine schwierige Frage, aber ich glaube schon, ich glaube, die Welt, in der wir leben, ist eine visuelle. Man glaube, man kann viel mehr Sachen machen, man kann einfach Dinge lesen, Dinge wahrnehmen, man kann sich besser in der Umgebung orientieren, mal irgendwie einkaufen gehen. Kannst du vergessen, wenn du nichts siehst, wenn du nur hörst. Du findest gar nichts, du kannst nichts kaufen. Du kaufst irgendwie eingelegte Gurken, obwohl du Nutella kaufen wolltest, da wieder eine Riesensauerei in der Küche. Da funktioniert überhaupt nichts, hören hilft dir da gar nicht. Du musst dann immer, du musst dann das Glas in die Hand nehmen und brüllst, ist das Nutella? Wir mussten diese Folge schon wieder an dieser Stelle unterbrechen, da Florentin das Ganze noch eine halbe Stunde weitergemacht hat. Wir geben die Folge jetzt gekürzt weiter. Also bei mir auf Platz eins, fühlen. Ist für mich der wichtigste Sinn, ich bin ein sehr emotionaler Mensch. Wünschst du mir? Erst mal die Frage, ist es jetzt dein innerer Wunsch, fühlend, dass es dein Lieblingssinn ist, oder willst du, dass fühlen dein Lieblingswunsch ist? Nein, es ist mein Lieblingswunsch. Okay. Es ist mein Lieblingswunsch. Hast du schon mal, eine Umarmung kann man nicht sehen, man kann sie nicht hören. Den Herzschlag eines geliebten Menschen kannst du nicht schmecken.
Sowas kann man nur fühlen, und das sind die wirklich wichtigen Dinge im Leben.
Und wer sagt, die Welt ist eine visuelle Welt, der hat überhaupt nichts verstanden.
Die Welt ist eine fühlbare Welt. Gänsehaut, Wind, Sand, Steine, Äste, das, das ist das wahre Leben. Ein weiteres Mal mussten wir die Folge an dieser Stelle unterbrechen. Es geht kürzt weiter. Radeberger, ein Radeberger. Was ich mich gefragt habe, wo landen eigentlich die Enden von Toastbrot? Zumal, wenn du nicht fühlst, kannst du ja auch nicht wirklich gut essen, weil du hast ja keine Konsistenz mehr. Na, ich weiss nicht, nein, nein. Oder? Die Zunge ist davon ausgewogen. Du kannst doch nicht mehr sprechen, wenn du nicht mehr fühlst. Aber wo landen eigentlich die Enten von Toastbrot? Keine Ahnung, also das ist immer so ein Ding, so, oh, die Enten von Toastbrot ist das Schlimmste der Welt und dann hat wieder jemand auf einen Eingag gepostet, oh, ich muss verhungern, weil ich habe nur noch die Enten von Toastbrot, da, Topvote auf die Frontpage, ha,
und da denke ich mir immer so, nee,
ich bin da wieder so ein Ding, das komplett an mir
vorbeigeht, mir ist das völlig egal, ob das das
Ende oder anfang ist. Ja, mir auch, ich will einfach nur wissen,
so what? Wenn ich Toastbrot kaufe,
habe ich noch nie Endstücke gehabt.
Nee, was?
Seltenst. Du hast doch bei jedem
Toastbrot Endstücke, das ist doch so ein Leibbrot.
Toastbrot, nein, die, die ich
kaufe, da sind keine
Endstücke da drin.
Er hat sich in der Zeit, dass er die Zeit, Leib Brot. Toastbrot, nein, die, die ich kaufe, da sind keine Endstücke da drin.
Wir reden von unterschiedlichen, wenn ich den Rewe die ein Toastbrot kaufe, ist da kein Endstück drin.
Es kann gut sein, dass sich das vielleicht sogar durchgesetzt hat, dass die nicht mehr verkauft werden mit Endstücken.
Aber wo kommen die denn hin?
Die werden eingestampft zu Hundefutter gemacht.
Sehr gut, danke.
Mein Gott.
Ja, das soll mir nicht meine Antwort. Was glaubst du, was denn in so einem Chicken McNugget drin ist? Toastbrot enden? Toastbrot. Alles ist aus Toastbrot heutzutage. So ein iPhone besteht zu 90 Prozent aus Toastbrot. Meinst du, wo das alles herkommt? Deswegen ist das wahnsinnig wertvoll. Deswegen soll man Händen dies auch zurückgeben, damit wieder Toastbrot draus gemacht werden kann. Sehr wertvoll. Die werden ja nur wertvoll durch den Namen. Wie ist das eigentlich bei dir? Also ich habe letztens so eine, also bei Galileo und so gibt es das ja wahnsinnig oft. Also wir sind tatsächlich auch im Bereich der Sinne. Jetzt kommt mal ein ernster Punkt, da möchte ich jetzt mal drüber reden. Und zwar gibt es ja immer dieses teurer Wein gegen billigen Wein oder nimm irgendwas anderes. Wir nehmen es mal Wein. Und dann geht man auf die Strasse, dann schickt man die Praktikanten los mit Kamerateam und dann hat man drei verschiedene Weine und einer ist teuer und einer ist billig und einer ist mittel und dann lässt man die Passanten trinken und dann stellt man fest, der teure Wein wird gar nicht als der beste festgestellt, sondern es gleicht sich aus oder was auch immer. Und dann sagt man den Leuten, ah, wir sagen ihnen jetzt, welcher der teure Wein ist und alle finden dann den teuren Wein am besten.
So, und dann haben wir Fazit, bla bla bla, es lohnt sich gar nicht, den teuren Wein zu kaufen.
Aber, wo ich mir immer denke, nee, wenn du den teuren Wein besser findest, weil er teuer ist, ist er trotzdem besser. Er hat dir deswegen trotzdem besser geschmeckt, auch wenn er jetzt vom reinen Materiellen nicht besser ist. Aber es geht nicht nur um das Materielle, es geht so gut wie gar nicht um das Materielle. Das Gehirn besteht noch aus viel mehr als einfach nur Geschmacksrezeptoren. Da ist sowas wie Statusdenken, wie stehe ich vor den anderen Leuten da, Ideologie, was heißt das eigentlich? Also natürlich spielt das auch mit rein und der teure Wein schmeckt besser, auch weil er teuer ist, aber er schmeckt auch einfach besser. Deswegen ist es auch gerechtfertigt. Das gehört genauso zum Produkt, die ganze Vermarktung, das Aussehen der Flasche, das Image der Firma, der Name. Das gehört genauso zum Produkt wie das tatsächliche physische Objekt selbst. Es ist ein Objektiv, also ich habe mittlerweile erfahren, dass Maschinen riechen können, also manche Maschinen können das, zum Beispiel in der Brauerei, im Brauereiwesen, da müssen Maschinen riechen, ob die Flasche anders befüllt wurde, zum Beispiel wenn Wasserflaschen abgefüllt werden, da muss man vorher daran riechen, dass da vorher keine Cola drin war zum Beispiel, also dass die Wasserflasche wieder mit Wasser befüllt werden kann.
Und deswegen haben anscheinend Maschinen ja raus, wie es funktioniert, wie Riechen funktioniert.
Und man kann man da nicht einfach, wenn Maschinen das schon können, muss man das doch mathematisch
auch ausrechnen können.
Und dann muss man doch sagen, gibt es den besten Geruch der Welt.
Ich kann nur an die arme Sau denken, die das gemacht hat, bevor es eine Maschine gemacht
hat, der den ganzen Tag da sitzt und jede einzelne Flasche riecht. Das ist doch wirklich, da riechst du doch durch. Das ist wirklich ein beschissener Job. Aber er war trotzdem sehr traurig, als irgendwann eine Maschine kam und sagte, ja, sorry, ich nehme jetzt einen Arbeitsplatz ein. Ja, aber auf den leeren Flaschen so einen Flötenton zu machen, das können die, das können Maschinen nicht, das kann nur ich. Jetzt raus bitte. Während er vom Sicherheitsdienst rausgetragen wurde, schrie er noch. Im Hintergrund war das Pfeifen der Maschine in die Flasche zu hören und der Mann fing an zu weinen. Als er rausgetragen wurde und er wurde nie wieder mit einem Lächeln. Wir sind da zu filmisch, denken wir heute, das ist gar nicht so schlecht. Ja, wir sind visuelle Menschen, ne? Also, wären wir auch so visuell, wenn wir nicht sehen würden? Also können sich blinde Menschen Dinge auch vorstellen? Ja! Das ist auch so eine Frage. Aber ich würde blinde Menschen gerne mal malen sehen. Wie der Herr, ne? Ich würde blinde Menschen gerne mal malen sehen. Also wie würden dich, wenn die, die sollen mal bitte malen können, so dass sie das malen können, was sie sich gerade vorstellen, wie die Welt aussieht. Oder träumen oder sowas, also träumen die dann in Gerüchen eher, weil also ist es das auch so, oder ist es auch so in der Urban Legend, dass wenn du einen Sinn verlierst, alle anderen Sinne automatisch besser werden. Das ist wirklich so, du hast ja ein Gehirn mit einer RAM-Leistung, so und wenn plötzlich dein Bildschirm nicht mehr funktioniert, ist dein RAM natürlich schneller. Ja, aber das ist ein schlechter Vergleich, weil nur weil du jetzt irgendwie deine Grafikkarte nicht benutzt, heißt das nicht, dass dein Rechner deswegen mehr Speicherplatz hat. Das funktioniert überhaupt nicht. Du hast einen Arbeitsspeicher frei. Und wenn der Arbeitsspeicher durch Grafikleistungen beeinträchtigt wird, dann hast du natürlich mehr Zeit und mehr Volumen dafür, wenn du das nicht mehr benutzt. Ja, aber mit den
haben sie uns, Smisma. Aber bei Kindern
ist es ja zum Beispiel auch so, wenn du drei Kinder
hast und eins stirbt, werden die anderen
besser, weil sozusagen die
Fähigkeiten von einem toten Kind auf die
anderen Kinder übertragen werden, auf die Geschwister.
Die haben dann die Fähigkeiten von dem
übernommen. Also wenn deine Oma stirbt,
ist die andere Oma automatisch die bessere
Oma, weil sie lebt. Richtig.
Das ist genau wie bei Aronal und Elmix. Wenn du
Aronal nicht mehr benutzt, wird Elmix
Das ist ein, was wironal und Elmex. Wenn du Aronal nicht mehr benutzt, wird Elmex automatisch ein bisschen Aronal. Aronal ist aber generell uncooler als Elmex. Also mir ersetzt zwei Aronal ersetzen mir einen Elmex, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Ja, wirklich? Mir ist ein Amex drei Aronal wert.
Ich würde drei Aronal gegen einen Amex tauschen.
Das ist hart.
Aber da bin ich total hart.
Du bist auch ein Morgenmensch eigentlich.
Du bist ein Morgenmensch.
Ich bin ein Morgenmensch, voll.
Aber da müsste ich eigentlich Aronal-Fan sein.
Wir mussten die Folge an dieser Stelle unterbrechen,
da sich Florentin und Stefan für eine halbe Stunde angeschwiegen haben. Wir geben die Folge geküsst weiter. Hast du eigentlich einen Lieblingsschuh, also jetzt im Sinne von linker Schuh oder rechter Schuh? Würdest du da sagen, so den linken, der mag ich nicht so. Nee, ich bin da, ähm, nee, nein. Ich bezweifle, dass irgendwer einen Lieblingsschuh hat. Ich weiß es nicht. Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, bei Handschuhen war das immer ganz stark so. Als Kind habe ich den ganzen Tag Handschuhe getragen, ständig, immer, auch im Sommer. Weil so ein verdammter Creep war es. Da dachte ich mir einfach, der Linke ist einfach gut. Manchmal hatte ich auch nur den linken Handschuh an, wie so ein Torwart, wie so ein, ich habe auch das schlechtem Fussball, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, so wie mit Paralympics, ich habe immer mit den behinderten Kindern Fussball gespielt und hier ist es, ja, aber nur mit dem linken Arm, sonst ist es ja unfair, so, das war, deswegen wurde ich auch. Und da wurde es immer als erstes ins Team gewählt. Ja, könnte man auch einen guten Tweet draus machen, Ja. Aber, liked ja niemand, muss ja man ja wieder löschen, wenn niemand faved. So ist es ja. Aber wie schärfst du deine Sinne? Man sagt ja auch, man kann seine Sinne schärfen, man kann seine Sinne optimieren, dass man wach durch die Welt geht. Wie machst du das? Du, ich habe tatsächlich ohne Witz fünf Minuten vor der Aufzeichnung, war ich echt am Boden emotional, ging es mir echt nicht gut. Und dann dachte ich mir, fuck, ich muss jetzt irgendwas machen, um besser im Podcast zu sein. Ich muss jetzt einfach irgendwas machen und habe wirklich auf meinem Handy mir so eine Gehirntrainer-App geholt und habe irgendwie noch fünf Minuten so Gehirntrainings gemacht, so merke dir Farben oder Sachen oder Kopfrechnen,
einfach weil ich dachte, dass ich damit mein Gehirn irgendwie ein bisschen auf Vordermann bringe,
dass ich im Podcast besser performe. Und ich meine, so wie du an meinen Skype-Anruf angenommen hast,
kann das nicht gut gelaufen sein.
Ich nehme an, im Kopfrechnen bist du kein Genie.
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Und es hat mich noch weiter runtergezogen und ich war noch schlechter drauf tatsächlich, weil ich gemerkt habe,
ich bin nicht nur traurig, sondern auch dumm
und es ist eine ganz schlechte Kombination.
Ja,
ich weiß nicht,
ich habe mal einen
Q-Test im Internet gemacht,
um, da habe ich schon mal erzählt,
da hatte ich 174.
Ja, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Das ist das mit den Vögeln, die man auf Schweine schießen muss, ne? Da hast du gut abgeschnitten. Ja, ja, aber du musst halt auch diese Eier finden zwischendurch, diese goldenen. Das ist der Trick. Ja, ja. Das war der Trick. Wenn ihr das macht, habt ihr auch alle 174. Wollen wir mal ein Gerücht streuen? Ein Geruch streuen vielleicht. Über Gerüche fällt mir nichts mehr ein, lass uns über Gerüchte sprechen. Wir arbeiten uns durch den Duden durch. Das ist eine sehr gute Idee. Alter, das ist eine sehr gute Idee. Ja, aber eigentlich schlecht. Ja, voll. Stell dir vor, wir machen das in zehn Jahren noch. Wir sind bei Gerüchen, bei Sinne, was für ein Dämiges kackt immer für ein Podcast, wo man nicht mal was zeigen kann. Das machen wir. Ich bin letztens in einem Auto gefahren, wo man seinen MP3-Player anschließen konnte. Allerdings konnte man seine Musik nur in alphabetischer Reihenfolge hören. Man konnte nicht irgendwie Alben auswählen und Interpreteten, sondern nur die Titel in Reihenfolge einfach angefangen. Und dann irgendwie bei T immer Titel eins, Titel eins, Titel eins. Was ist musikalisch ein Lieblingsbuchstabe? Das ist eine gute Frage. C wahrscheinlich. Viele Lena-Songs fangen mit C an. Candlelight zum Beispiel. Oder Coco. Candle in the wind. Candle in the wind, Coconut bar. Can't dance. Nenn mal fünf Songs, die mit F anfangen. Jetzt los! Flogging Molly, Foo Fighters. Nein. Bitte, lassen hier mal Interpreten nehmen. Okay, von mir aus, ist noch schwerer, fünf Interpreten mit F, go. Foo Fighters, Flogging Molly, die Fantastischen Vier, Foo Fighters und und Fritz Kalkbrenner. Okay, Franz Fähnand und Fatboy Slim. Okay. Ja, gut. Einfach mal um dich mal ein bisschen... Nenn du mal zehn Bands mit K. Kraftklub, Crow, Carmina Burana, Krüso, ähm. Warum, du kannst einfach Krüso sagen. Es wäre genauso falsch gewesen, aber es wäre auch wenigstens klanglich richtig gewesen. Äh, TKKG, ähm, Legotechnik, der Technik von Saturn, Kuklux-Clan, Karlsson vom Dach, Karl Urban, ja, passt so. Danke. Wir waren in der Schule in den KKK-Tagen und zwar stand es mit Kommunikation, Kontakt und Krapfen, weil es danach noch so ein Buffet gab und es von der Bäckerei gesponsert wurde. Aber ich kann mich noch erinnern, wo ich damals in der letzten Reihe saß, neben einem guten Freund von mir, der schwarz war, und die Lehrerin angekündigt hat, Kinder, ihr müsstet euch den Zettel ausfüllen. Zwei Wochen fahren wir in die KKK-Tage und wie er einfach plötzlich ganz bleich geworden ist oder halt was auch immer, irgendwie noch dunkler oder was auch immer, keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall. Wie beim Erzählen der Geschichte noch rassistischer bist als der Inhalt. Als die Rass... Auf jeden Fall wurden seine Augen plötzlich ganz gross, also noch grösser als seine Lippen. Also jetzt, wenn er Lippen wurden, also je nachdem, also wie es halt passiert, ne, also naja, auf jeden Fall, er konnte eh nicht schreiben, von daher hätte er eh nicht mitkommen können. Naja, auf jeden Fall war das sehr, tatsächlich sehr erheiternd. War ein guter Mann. Wurde auch verhaftet tatsächlich, oder später. Aber weil er schwarz ist, nicht weil du weißt, dass er verhaftet wurde. Ne, ja. Das war in Bayern immer so die drei schwersten Menschen wurden verhaftet. Oder verbrannt. Oder verbrannt. Je nachdem, dürfte man sich aussuchen. Ja, ich liebe Gerüche, Chlor oder Benzin. Welche Sinne am ehesten verlieren? Top fünf Sinne. Ja, wir sind durch. Also ich bin durch. Ich habe meine Liste komplett. Nächste Woche gibt es das, was im Duden nach Gerüche steht, Leute. Wollen wir nicht noch ein Gerücht streuen? Okay, ein Gerücht streuen. Und zwar, wir streuen das Gerücht ... Stefan Tietze hat mit Twitter aufgehört. Tietze. Stefan Tietze hat sich von Twitter verabschiedet. Stefan Tietze. Sehr gut. Nee, und zwar streuen wir das Gerücht, dass Florentin Will jetzt Alkohol trinkt. Mhm, okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Let's streu. Okay. Aufgabe an alle da draußen. Ja. Eure Aufgabe ist es, auf eurem Schulhof zu erzählen. Hey, hey, hey, Bianca, komm mal her. Hey, komm mal her, komm mal her. Nur weil ich schwarz bin, heißt es nicht, dass ich lüge. Pass mal auf Folgendes. Florentin will vom Das-Podcast-Ufo trinkt jetzt Alkohol. Genau so
macht er das morgen wieder auf dem Schulhof.
Okay?
Bist du noch da? Streuen wie ein Lauffeuer.
Streuen wie
Streuselkäse. Ich bin noch da. Wie heißt das da?
Ich möchte mich von den...
Staubzucker.
Wie riecht eigentlich Zucker?
Bitte spiel nie wieder
vor der Aufnahme irgendeine Gehirn-Jogging-Show.
Nie wieder.
Du bist so ganz komisch auf Zack.
Ganz komisch keck.
Ja.
Irgendwie mit Pfiff.
Ich bin heute ein bisschen mit Pfiff tatsächlich.
Aber so die negative Art von Pfiff.
Du wiederholst auch jeden Satz, den du erzählst.
Du wiederholst jeden Satz so.
Ja, aber du mir reinredest.
Nein.
Ich habe letztens eine Bekannte in der U-Bahn gesehen.
Und die habe ich schon seit drei Jahren nicht mehr gesehen. Und ich habe sie gar nicht erkannt, weil die ist schwarz geworden in der Zeit.
Und das war echt weird, wo ich mir dachte, what? Also nur weil du mit einem Schwarzen schläfst, habe ich das anders verstanden irgendwie. Aber man mischt sich dann so ein bisschen. Und sie hiess auch ganz anders. Sie ist sehr dick geworden, aber sie hiess ganz anders.
Und sie hat gesagt, die ganze Zeit hat sie behauptet, ja hör auf, mit einer ganz anderen Stimme auch, hör auf mich zu belästigen, ich bin nicht der, wer du meinst, ganz komische Situation. Hat auch ganz anders gerochen. Das war peinlich. In diesem Sinne, das waren Florentin und Stefan vom Podcast UFO. Vielen Dank Stefan, dass du uns heute wieder zugehört hast. Vielen Dank an alle Zuhörer da draussen. Schreibt doch mal so ein bisschen in die Kommentare, was eure Lieblingsgerüche sind oder warum ihr lieber mit weißen Menschen abhängt als mit schwarzen. Und wenn ihr Florantins Handy-Nummer haben wollt, dann schreibt doch einfach, ich habe immer gesagt, bei Skype kann man das Podcast-Sufo jetzt annehmen und kann uns Voicemail hinterlassen. Habe ich versucht selber, ich wurde ja mittlerweile angenommen vom Das Podcast Sufo, und man kann
an Florin die Sendynummer sehen. Das finde ich lustig.
In diesem Sinne, versucht das
doch mal. Und dann
habt ihr die alle zum Verschicken
und Tauschen. Okay,
aber muss nicht sein, ne? Also,
gut, oh,
höre ich da etwa schon die Musik reinkommen?